[Music]
now also during my interview with
California governor Gavin Newsom I
pressed him about progressive tax policy
and how much he really thinks that top
earners should be taxed take a look how
much is enough when terms of the amount
of money that government takes all
across the board now if you live in
California and you're part of that evil
one percent or the top 15 not the evil
one percent thank you we thank you for
give me all your money thank you for for
hiring people that do the free
enterprise do the math thank you do the
math with me 40 federal income tax the
highest marginal rate and Biden wants it
higher 13.3 so that's
53.3 of cents okay sales tax around
seven percent and you got these
millionaire taxes now they put new laws
in effect in La for example 10 million
dollar house is going to cost you what
five hundred thousand dollars in a tax
uh just to sell your house transfer
taxes okay that's insane
um okay by the way
how much out of every dollar should even
the wealthiest the wealthiest get to
keep because when you die the government
comes in and takes half of it how much
or 40 how much does the State of
California have for death tax I don't
know when Ronald Reagan governor living
in here I'm asking when Gavin newsom's
president let me just say this
I have a license Governor there's a slip
of the tongue we're talking about it
we're talking about debt and deficits
issues of entitlements
issues of spending no no no and tax cuts
something has to give I am something has
to give how much out of every dollar
clearly and by the way that answer by
the way there's no black or white on
that there's no it should be this for
everybody there's different conditions
different states so for the top 15 20 of
people that make the most money how much
out of every dollar they make should
they be able to keep at the end of the
day all times if I'm the president
United States I've one answer to that
I'm Governor I have another answer mayor
I have another I'm looking for your
philosophy I believe in progressive tax
policy not regressive tax policy I
believe in doing what we can to protect
the minimum
those that have done well okay uh it
should pay a little bit more you know
what and I don't I don't begrudge their
success every dollar they make I aspire
to be them I love these folks every
dollar they make how much should they be
able to keep I don't know they were
surviving with 70 tax rates under Ronald
Reagan the guy who used to live in this
building okay you know what we had the
most high marginal rates to 28 the
lowest but in the 50s and 60s and 70s
where the Temple of the world economy in
a way that was unimaginable built the
world's largest reception double-digit
interest rates inflation he gave us the
longest at the time period of a period
of uh peacetime economic growth that had
trickled down economics and created 21
million new jobs yeah and and a lot of
exacerbated conditions that we're still
trying to deal with as it relates to
Injustice back to blame Reagan no I'm
not blaming Reagan for everything a lot
of Democrats do in fact I Inspire on gun
policy to be Ronald Reagan who said
AK-47s should not be used for defense
and he believes in backgrounds
not only AK-47 AR different platforms
M16s I shot a Gatling gun a 15 caliber
means you actually know what AR means I
shot a musket you saw it yeah and it's
still trying to get the it's amazing
right I mean with all this year with a
musket these weapons award don't need
they're not deer in their sights by the
way I follow I'm a Avid gun by the way
when I lived here I had a license legal
license to carry did you I did Ronald
Reagan
I know different very different by the
way by the way states with those those
laws have higher than I read your
constitutional amendment I am actually a
gun safety nut love that okay well my
mom was a prison guard and she had a
revolver on her nightstand and she knew
I was a pretty curious and let's say
incorrigible child and the odds were
that I was going to touch it and my dad
was a family court probation officer but
they took me like 10 or 11 years old and
brought me to a range and taught me
firearm safety and I sat there that day
and then the guy says repeat back
everything I said gun down range how to
deal with the jam gun I never pointed at
anybody uh it's all the rules and how to
clear it and he said okay you did great
if you come back next week and you can
tell me all that I'll let you fire the
gun you wouldn't let me fire it you know
what it did when I first fired it it
taught me respect for safety yeah and
and I love that Spirit Sean I'm all for
that for common sense but don't tell me
I can't have an AR-15 when it's not any
different than most other guns except
cosmetically it's not me to sell I mean
you're your own Fox News Paul says 87 of
people want background checks they
believe if you can buy a beer can't buy
a beer you shouldn't be able to buy a
gun a little bit of background check we
don't have it it's hers With A Gun Show
loophole closures we don't have it at
the extent we can't have it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else